what role does Love play in The Human
Condition we haven't brought up love and
this whole picture we talked about
intelligence we talked about
Consciousness it seems part of humanity
I would say one of the most important
parts is this feeling we have
towards each other
if in the future there were routinely
more than one AI let's say two for the
sake of discussion who would look at
each other and say I am I and you are
you the other one also says I am I and
you are you and like
and sometimes they were happy and
sometimes they were sad and it mattered
to the other one that this thing that is
different from them is like
they would rather it be happier than sad
and entangle their lives together
then
this is
a more optimistic thing than I expect to
actually happen and a little fragment of
meaning would be there
possibly more than a little but that I
expect this to not happen that I do not
think this is what happens by default
that I do not think that this is the
future we are on track to get
is
why would go down fighting rather than
you know just saying oh well
do you think that is part of the meaning
of this whole thing or the meaning of
life
what do you think is the meaning of life
of human life
it's all the things that I value about
it and maybe all the things that I would
value if I understood it better
there there's not some meaning far
outside of us that we have to to wonder
about there's just like
looking at life and being like yes this
is what I want
there there's the the meaning of life
has not
some kind of like like
meaning is something that we bring to
things when we look at them we look at
them and we say like this is its meaning
to me and there's like there's it's not
that before Humanity was ever here there
was like some meaning written upon the
Stars where you could like go out to the
star where that meaning was written and
like change it around and thereby
completely change the meaning of life
right like like the the notion that this
is written on a stone tablet somewhere
implies you could like change the tablet
and get a different meaning and that
seems kind of wacky doesn't it
so it's it's it doesn't feel that
mysterious to me at this point it's just
a matter of being like yeah I care
I care
and part of that is uh
part of that is the love that connects
all of us it's one of the things that I
care about
and the flourishing of the collective
intelligence of the human species
you know that sounds kind of too fancy
to me I just look at all the all the
people you know like one by one up to
the 8 billion and be like that's life
that's life that's life
you're an incredible human it's a huge
honor I was uh trying to talk to you for
a long time
because I'm a big fan I think you're a
really important voice a really
important mind thank you for the fight
you're fighting
um thank you for being fearless and bold
and for everything you do I hope we get
a chance to talk again and I hope you
never give up
thank you for talking to this you're
welcome I do worry that we
they didn't really address a whole lot
of fundamental questions I expect people
have but you know maybe
we got a little bit further and made a
tiny little bit of progress and uh
I'd say like be satisfied with that but
actually no I think one should only be
satisfied with solving the entire
problem
to be continued